foreign
[Music]
an author a Storyteller and a corporate
Communications leader based in Singapore
from the lead galvanizer cohort
I'm delighted to be here today
to start with please accept my apologies
for not being able to do this in person
I've just had a surgery and have been
advised not to travel until I recover
fully
I'm hoping you will forgive me for this
and will listen and find my story just
as engaging nonetheless
until the age of six I lived with my
parents in various small towns in remote
India
some of these places did not have
schools and what that meant was that I
was left with little option to be
formally educated
when I turned six my dad took up a new
job in a mid-sized Suburban town in
odisha in eastern India
there was only one English medium School
in that little town
my parents were naturally very impatient
about my education so they approached Mr
Roy the principal of sunshine public
school to see if I could be accommodated
I obviously could not take a test
because I really knew nothing except
what I was taught at home
after much bleeding the kind-hearted Mr
Roy agreed to take me in his school
despite no seats and I was allowed to
just sit in class
I had to prove myself in three months
before the school would officially admit
me
so I was directly admitted to Upper
kindergarten in the last three months of
the academic calendar and when I joined
school we were already on chapter 23 of
the radiant reader
to top it all I was not a registered
student
I still remember how it made me cringe
every time the teacher did a roll call
in class I was an outsider a non-entity
in the upper kindergarten class in short
I was the invisible newcomer the extra
chair in class
for some reason it hurt my little pride
a bit
that was of course one of the many small
challenges I had as a six-year-old
the medium of instruction was English
and children weren't allowed to speak in
any other language at the school not in
class nor in the playground
now I didn't speak English
I had never had a chance to learn the
language
so I withdrew into a shell because I
couldn't just speak to anyone I couldn't
communicate or socialize I had no
friends and school was a space I did not
enjoy at all
school was some 20 miles from home and
every morning when the pickup Jeep came
I would pretend I was just dead because
I hated everything about that school
what a terrible thing for a child to go
through
now even as I struggled to read a line
in English grappled with forming
sentences I was tasked to write question
and answers from late Kate and Simple
Simon
that I scored a 4 out of 25 in the first
unit test was no surprise
my mother had tears in her eyes when the
form teacher told her how terrible I was
my father was furious and I remember him
throwing away the horrid homework book
with red cross marks all over
only I did not know what was wrong all I
remember from that moment is a little
helpless girl running out of the house
to the backyard ashamed lost wondering
what is happening where am I failing
also I clearly remember a day I felt
sick and could not report it because I
couldn't communicate in English I was so
helpless
I suffered in silence and cried till
someone came to help me
it was a life-changing moment for a
six-year-old
I had never felt so inadequate before
but even as a child I made a promise to
myself that I would equip myself with
what I lacked today so that I can always
be battle ready and I learned what it
takes to get there no matter how tough
the challenge is I told myself
now I started reading English wherever I
could find it newspapers Billboards
books grocery paper bags and trying to
make sense of every word and sentence I
read I literally devoured every word
with the hunger of a famous child
that December I fell ill and I remember
I answered my annual exams with a very
high temperature my dad draped me in a
thick red coat and drove me in his Jeep
to the school I also remember he sat
there as I took my test
Now by some fluke of Destiny when the
results were out I had not only beaten
my own records I had beaten everyone
else in class and picked up a second
rank my mum as emotional as all mums are
ended up crying again when she came to
collect my report book
the school principal remember Mr Roy as
generous as only he could be I announced
a special award for the student who was
not registered I received my first book
Cinderella as a special price from him
in the school assembly
I never scored a second rank again in
sunshine public school and topped the
class in all subsequent years in English
no matter where I studied thereafter
now why am I telling you all this
my journey from that six-year-old to
Leading narrative and content for one of
the largest privately held companies in
the world being a published author of
short stories in English getting
recognized as one of the top three
Indian authors in 2022 is an outcome of
that single promise
equip yourself step up and turn your
biggest challenge into your greatest
opportunity
never miss a chance to learn a new skill
take a new course enroll in a training
and become an upgraded version of
yourself
most importantly never give up on
and that's my message to you today
always always be battle ready you never
know when a challenge will be thrown at
you and you could turn that challenge
into an opportunity
thank you for listening to me
[Applause]
[Music]